jeff whittake sues david dobrik in a
multi-million dollar lawsuit in court
docks obtained by e.t jeff seeks 10
million dollars in damages related to
his injuries from the stunt they filmed
together in 2020. the jeff thing is
is the worst the worst thing that's ever
happened to me jeff was once part of
david's quote vlog squad collaborating
on viral videos
many featuring celebrity appearances
while others focused on potentially
dangerous activities
in one such stunt filmed in june 2020
jeff was tied to an excavator operated
by david in the lawsuit filing jeff
alleges david spun the construction
equipment at unsafe speeds leading jeff
to collide with the excavator david
eventually shared footage of the
incident to youtube but the post has
since been removed
how long to like a fight
jeff claims he suffered a broken skull
facial fractures and eye damage
the court docks cite general negligence
on david's part as a result jeff alleges
his injuries impacted him financially
due to hospital bills and turning down
job opportunities
e.t has reached out to both jeff and
david for comment jeff has chronicled
his recovery on social media like this
post from february where jeff said he
completed his ninth surgery i've been
protecting this guy for so long and
there's so much more to the story the
two have been vocal about the incident
on their respective platforms in
february jeff didn't mince words on his
podcast i just want to tell the truth
finally like i gave this i gave this
[ __ ] so many chances i woke up
from surgery
and a day goes by no text from him
another day goes by no text at one point
jeff references a potential lawsuit
months before eventually filing one
against david imagine you smash somebody
sculling they take it on the chin they
don't sue you they don't can press
charges i would nearly die they came an
inch from death an
inch from going blind the following
month david reflected on his podcast i
wish it was me up there i wish whatever
like it's like
it's the most unfortunate thing ever and
i think
and and
and it's a it's an accident that's what
it was it's an accident david reiterates
his claim that the stunt was actually
jeff's idea
i think one of the main reasons
um
jeff is bummed with me right now is um
because he saw me do
uh
he saw me do an interview
where i said something
that i promised him i'd keep between us
he's like can you can you can you
promise me one thing i said what he's
like can you just promise that no one
ever knows that this was my idea as
david tells it he remains torn up about
the whole thing and accepts a certain
level of responsibility he got hurt
because i was driving that's it and i
know that that'll be the biggest regret
of my life
my entire life i really hope there's not
a moment that that i regret as much as
that one